president trump says the government will
send up to 125
million reusable face masks to school
to help them reopen on time ben tracy
looks at the president's
newest medical ally in his effort to get
students
back in classrooms so this is the first
time i've shared the platform
and it's an honor to do so at the white
house wednesday
president trump introduced his new
coronavirus advisor
dr scott atlas the president's priority
is to open the schools and open them
safely
atlas a frequent fox news guest has
praised the president's handling of the
virus
and shares many of his inaccurate views
much of the stuff on mass really is real
is not very good science at all atlas
calls keeping kids out of school
ludicrous this is a level of hysteria
like this is something i feel like i'm
living in a kafka novel here
since restarting his coronavirus
briefings last month
president trump has not included the
government's health experts
dr deborah burks and dr anthony fauci
who have at times contradicted the
president
there should be universal wearing of
masks on wednesday president trump
unveiled eight recommendations for
schools
but they are not new and are very basic
including frequent hand washing
social distancing and wearing masks all
schools should be making plans to resume
in-person
classes as soon as possible
polls show a growing majority of voters
59 percent
oppose the trump administration's demand
that schools
fully reopen for in-person learning
that's up from 53 percent
last month the white house and
congressional democrats say they want
more than 100 billion dollars in aid for
schools but negotiations over the larger
stimulus bill
are now at a complete impasse yesterday
the two sides put out dueling statements
accusing each other
of being unwilling to compromise anthony
ben tracy thanks ben